Lucretius is on the nature of things is
one of the great instances of cultural
mobility this was a text a poem
remarkable poem written more than 2,000
years ago itself based on ideas that are
at least several hundred years older
than that it had some circulation at the
time of Cicero and Julius Caesar and the
poet Virgil and then after a few hundred
years of such circulation it disappeared
and is scarcely mentioned for more than
a thousand years and then one day in
January of 1417 a book hunter now
obscure papal bureaucrat made watcher
broccolini went into a monastic library
and he found a copy and he took it off
the shelf and that taking it off the
shelf and recirculating it getting it
copied and having it begin once again to
be read turned out to have
extraordinarily far-reaching
consequences though by no means
immediately it was just more like
butterfly's wing moving initially just a
tiny bit of movement and this is for me
the rediscovery of this ancient poem in
fourteen seventeen is the paradigmatic
instance of recirculation of what it
means for something to be put back in
motion why is it significant because of
everything that had been lost much of
the classical heritage in general was
lost many many plays by Sophocles and
Euripides and Aeschylus many great works
of art many great works of philosophy
and of science and so forth in the
general collapse of ancient civilization
among the things that didn't survive was
the school of philosophy called
epicureanism and the Greek world and it
was that school of philosophy that was
hanging by a thread in effect in this
one great poem Lucretia
on the nature of things that came back
with that poem came back the idea that
the world is made up out of Adam
and emptiness and nothing else no
mysterious demons no angels no forces
moving the atoms around that everything
can come into existence without
Providence that you don't need a creator
you don't need intelligent design to
understand how complex beings in the
universe ants or cockroaches or humans
can exist they come to exist because the
atoms have been crashing together for
untold thousands tens of thousands
millions billions of years and then that
clashing together eventually evolved
fantastically complex forms with that
comes the idea that the sole human soul
is made up out of atoms because there's
only atoms nothing more atoms and
emptiness the human soul is made up out
of atoms just as the body is made up out
of atoms and that the soul will
disintegrate when the body disintegrates
therefore there's no afterlife therefore
there's no judgment in the afterlife no
punishment no reward whatever meaning we
have in the universe is here and now in
this world and whatever political
ethical moral meanings we can make we
have to make here and now by ourselves
because there is no God who will
determine whether we've made the right
decisions or not and rewarded punish us
accordingly and so forth and so on
including the belief as Lucretia says
that there must have been because of
this notion other creatures who existed
in the earth of the species that existed
before us and other species who will
exist after us because nature is
constantly experimenting and those
things that can find food for themselves
and reproduce will probably persist for
some period of time those things that
can't do so will disappear and
eventually everything will disappear and
transform in the endless dance of
mutations of the atoms now all of that
came back in one piece
in 1417 because the rest of it the whole
philosophical tradition all of
Democritus all of Lucifer's almost all
of Epicurus is lost and lost forever
and then this text this magnificent poem
came back
there were only a handful of copies two
maybe three possibly that existed in the
world a fire an earthquake an act of
destruction would have done it in but it
came back in this one moment when a
obscure clerk took the book off the
shelf for me this is one of the great
thrilling stories
[Music]